[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens m'écouter j'aime
beaucoup de transport entre d'un
parisien je les prends tout le temps
parce que je trouve que c'est très
pratique et maintenant je prends
beaucoup des autobus et votre soeur bon
ce quoi ma soeur belle prend si les
transports en commun parce que la
voiture c'est plus possible dans paris
alors on préfère prendre les transports
en commun et aux modes solo c'est ça non
eh ben je suis un prix pourtant j'ai 70
ans je viens d'apprendre cette semaine
on est content c'est un gag pour sept
votes seraient alors on n'est pas les
mêmes et au sein des soeurs jumelles ya
trop de monde et mais bon pas la base
moi ça me dérange pas parce que vu que
je travaille la nuit et votre elle en
pense quoi je m'attendais à ça roule
tranquillement ouah ça va on est là
tranquille ça c'est dur et mon potager
juste des trucs ouais mon pote toi pas
peut-être d'ailleurs j'en profite que
taper un peu d'argent me dépanne bien il
faudrait 2000 wallon nous venons même l
or noir une chicha et kalenna on est la
joie de ces ça on est en ruines aux amis
d'amis en pareil même pu ouvrir la
chicha ses excédents
autrement j'utilise vélib depuis le
début et ça c'est le pied et votre heure
ils en pensent quoi votre frère qu'est
ce qu'ils en pensent
le pas de frère ouvriers on n'aime pas
le franc jeu tantôt devant un bourre-pif
cette femme bizarre c'est vite passé
vite je vais te dire un truc mon pote tu
de médecins dans les chicots toi t'en
rappeler que présente tony yoka ok c'est
mes deux meilleurs potes à éviter ratez
pas me laisser emmerder par un micro
c'est 8 safran ge a way bien toi une
bagarre sur le parking d'auchan
tu trouves que j'ai pris cher mon pote
vrai que soit sa gueule un bon ok ouais
j'en ai un bourre-pif porte de
versailles c'était prévu dans le nom
mais c'est vous le connaissez pas à pas
le nom mon avis c'est quelqu'un qui
passait comme ça car envie de s'amuser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]